I've spent the past two years looking
for my ex-girlfriends killer but no one
will do it
my cousin nice to be really close and I
mean really close but the last things
giving me economy having sex with his
girlfriend and we haven't spoken since
I'm sure I'll get over it eventually
though you know I mean he's only 12 it's
a new joke I'm sorry it makes me sound
like a pervert she was wearing makeup
you wanna mean like my girlfriend now is
cool though
you know we fight sometimes every fight
we get into it's always my fault you
know I should just keep my mouth shut
but I can't because I'm so [ __ ] funny
a couple nights ago we went to partying
just got hammered drunk out of our minds
the next one we wake up in bed together
absolutely hungover and I know I should
just be quiet but instead I roll over
and I say listen baby don't get mad but
I think your mama tried to have sex with
me last night and she hit the roof she
goes Anthony that's impossible I said oh
well in that case you should always wear
makeup my baby brother is in high school
now and we're close but sometimes let's
try to take advantage of that you know a
couple months ago he calls me up he goes
Anthony I just cut school for no reason
and now I need you to write me a sick
note and then forge dad's signature and
make it good and I did my best but I'm
horrible stuff like that teachers took
one look at the note said Mikey you
expect me to believe this you don't have
AIDS
like I've got a kid in Africa yeah I've
got a kid in Africa that I feed that I
clothe that I school that I inoculate
for 75 cents a day which is practically
nothing compared to what it cost to send
him that I got caught masturbating to a
National Geographic magazine not my
finest hour
I don't know who was more embarrassed to
me or my dentist this past weekend I had
to go to Boston with my girlfriend
stay with her dad could not have been
more uncomfortable you wouldn't let her
sleep in the same bedroom together yeah
you're sorry buddy I just don't trust
you I said trust me buddy I'm [ __ ]
your daughter one of my friends has
gotten so many duis they he had to go to
jail for a year now his only concern was
getting raped so he didn't take a shower
for the entire year because he was so
busy getting raped
why did the Muslim cross the road
because he was being relocated by
Israeli authorities to make more room
for Jewish settlements on the West Bank
this is funny my family is exactly like
the Brady Bunch
we may not be perfect but my father did
die from AIDS